hey everybody it's Jesse today we're
going to go over props and passing data
into react components with props so this
is going to be pretty pretty basic so if
you're already familiar with props you
probably won't learn anything new before
we get into that I just want to go over
a couple of things the website now has a
new launch date so it's supposed to
launch tomorrow and now we have until
May 25th to launch which is good news if
you remember we had a back-up plan and
that was just to launch a static site
but now we we don't have to we have more
time and we can build out all the react
components and launch the site that'd be
more in line with how how I wanted it to
be anyway hey everybody
as some people saying hello in the live
chat thanks for watching I think I
started a minute early so there we go we
got some more people coming in no it was
weird at first it said no one was
watching which is crazy because I had
some people waiting maybe it's just a
little delay in the analytics reminded
me of my first live streams when it was
just me talking to no one
so next week is going to be a crazy
schedule and I mentioned it a couple
times that it would be different than
normal but I've kind of thought through
when I I really could stream and Monday
and Tuesday are just so booked up with
meetings I think the only time that I
could stream is 11:30 a.m. Eastern Time
so Monday Tuesday that time will be
different
so hopefully
everybody who's kind of a normal viewer
will will see this and they won't miss
it the recording will still be available
so you'll still catch everything you
just won't be able to participate in the
live chat Wednesday I will be travelling
I have an early flight to Charleston
South Carolina for a conference so I'm
not really sure if there's going to be
lashing that day or not it depends on
whether the flight goes well and nothing
is delayed and what the Wi-Fi is like at
the hotel
so we'll see Wednesday maybe there'll be
something I'll try to let everybody know
through through Twitter and then I'll
schedule the event so you'll be able to
see the event time if I can so Wednesday
might not be anything Thursday and
Friday these are the days of the syntax
con conference that I'm going to I don't
know for sure what times during the
conference I'll be able to livestream
but I'd like to do some live streams
from the conference it probably won't be
me coding and this also is dependent on
the Wi-Fi available at the conference if
it can handle a live stream but I'm
thinking maybe I can livestream some
video from my phone I haven't done
mobile livestream on YouTube so maybe oh
I'll have to read more about it and see
exactly how to do it but that's what I'm
thinking let me know if you're
interested in that I'm not exactly sure
I mean maybe if I can talk to some of
the speakers and do maybe do a little
interview or something I don't know it
might be interesting it should be good
quality I have the one of the pixel
phones so the cameras a pretty decent
quality I don't know I mean it can take
4k video but I really doubt that I'd be
the network can handle streaming that so
maybe if I can get at least 720p that I
think it'd be worthwhile to stream ok so
that's it for the schedule next week let
me know in the comments or in the live
chat if
you would be interested at all and
seeing some sort of stream from the
conference if you guys want to see it
then I'll really try to do it otherwise
maybe maybe not and I've had a lot of
people asking me for new videos like on
topics so not a live stream but just
breaking down maybe a shorter video on a
specific topic a lot of people ask me
about my build tools you know how I just
how I have my workflow set up we're
different topics like somebody asked
yesterday about sass the CSS
preprocessor sass and like how that
works
so I'm going to do that and I have a
list of topics and if you have any top
that you want me to talk about let me
know but right now the top priority for
me is getting this site that we've been
working on launched so I'm guessing I
won't have time to make those videos
until after the site launches so expect
some new videos after May 25th and then
I'll try maybe in the mornings oh I'll
try to come in early but when it's quiet
and get some videos recorded and post as
many as I can
alright so today is Thursday I don't
know if you guys are Spotify users but
every Thursday they have a throwback
Thursday playlist I was listening to
that playlist this week and it was from
I think the year 2000 and it got me
feeling nostalgic so I thought I would
do a throwback Thursday to start things
out of a website that I built in the
early 2000s I can't remember exactly
what year if I had to guess maybe I'd
say 2003 so I'm gonna put this over here
so you can see it and don't don't make
fun of me too much but I don't
understand if you want to make fun of me
let me switch over here so this is one
of the first sites that I ever did
professionally meaning I got paid to do
it so I'm using the word professional
here just in the sense that I get paid
not in the sense that I was any good so
this website remains largely on
changed I will tell you though I did not
put this in and right now I'm uted the
sound but there's actually a voice over
when you go to this website and I didn't
put that in I'm not sure if the counter
still works or not well as CEO over
14,000 views right that's that's
respectable so this is for a local
community center that I did this so I've
come a long way since then
alright also I want to thank you thank
everybody for being so awesome and on
social media and in the comments what
year published I think 2003 I think
that's when I published it somewhere
around there if not 2003 you know give
or take a year or two you guys would be
nice about that website it was I I'll
throw it back on just one more time this
little section here I'm not sure what's
going on up here this wasn't there when
I first made it but this little section
drove me crazy and at the time I
couldn't figure out how to get rid of
this little white section there uh and I
I just it wasn't like it was like one of
those pre-made website builder things so
it wasn't like I was really doing any
coding you know very much coding at all
but um it got the job done people still
go to this site from from what I've I
haven't asked about it in a while but
the last time I asked about it which is
maybe a year or two ago they said people
still go to the site they still download
different forms they need and and get
what they need from it so it still
functions but you can see my name is
nowhere on this site if you won't see
this in my portfolio
okay somebody says they're looking
forward to watching this whole series
awesome we have a good evening from
Pakistan awesome welcome yeah if you
guys want to put in the live chat where
you're watching from I think you know
that's always cool to see where
everybody's had I did want to show you a
small milestone sorry the kind of the
interest taking a while but I prepared a
little bit ahead of time so we should be
able to get through everything quicker
than normal
little milestone for me my twitter has
over 100 followers so that's that may be
a very small amount for some of you I'm
sure you have a lot more followers than
that but that was that was cool for me
that's that's a nice little personal
milestone I know a lot of you're
following me if you do follow me on
Twitter I will tweet out the times that
I'm doing all the live streams
beforehand so I don't tweet that much
but I do try to tweet out the times at
least so it's another way for you to get
get the times I think if you subscribe
to this channel as well you'll get an
alert at least I get an alert on my
phone and in my email when a live stream
is going to happen alright so I think I
think that's everything I wanted to say
at first now let's start with some some
code all right we got the Netherlands
London Nairobi also okay coding
tutorials 360 is asked if I'd be
interested in being interviewed to talk
about react yeah I'd definitely be
interested go ahead and send me uh you
could put some in the comments if you
want to send me a private message do it
on Twitter that's that's what
everybody's been doing I usually so yeah
if you guys have a question you don't
want to put it in the comments you know
I totally understand if you're not
comfortable commenting for every book
the whole world to see I I'm usually the
type that kind of doesn't comment on
things and stays kind of quiet online so
just direct message me on Twitter and I
can answer any questions that you have
so yeah I'm definitely happy to do an
interview you want
we have Ghana Alabama Guatemala
Guatemala Philippines San Francisco
India u.s. awesome we have people from
everywhere I just think that every time
I see that it's always so cool I just
don't get tired of seeing people from
all over the world so let's get to a
little bit of this code we'll go back
over here and show you I've done some of
the work already so usually I just kind
of do everything you know as we're going
but I started on this will start
properly tutorial yeah we're starting
we're starting the tutorial not yeah
back to me egg that somebody told me
ignore the live check and chat good
advice so I'm going to ignore it for a
while I'll come back to it later on
before we end the video so I've blown
this up a lot so it's kind of hard to
see and I have a lot of inline Styles
right now which eventually I'll clean
this up and they probably won't be
inline but for now yeah I don't think
I'm nothing at the end of this is
important for what we're doing right now
so we can safely ignore that what we're
worried about
for now are let's see this props
component here okay so we have this
props title we're passing those props in
so this is the about page so I've copied
into a lot of that boilerplate that we
worked on for the index page and I took
out the hero section since we don't have
to here a section on the interior pages
and you see I've added this title
component
that we just saw and in the title
component I have two properties one is
just called title and I'm passing in
about as the title the other one I've
named image path and I'm passing in the
path of the image that I want so
whenever this component goes to get
rendered these are the props that get
passed in so now we go back over to the
component this makes a little bit more
sense so the title of the page which in
this case is about gets put in right
here we've used this dot props title and
we've put that in brackets so in react
if you want to add in some JavaScript in
the middle so we're inside this render
function this is basic its HTML it looks
just like regular HTML for the most part
but then we can drop right into
JavaScript right in the middle of our
HTML as long as we have in brackets so
this part is the JavaScript and we can
grab those props this is what allows us
to reuse components so I can use the
same title component on every page and
all I have to do on that page I'll flip
back over is just put in the correct
title since we want a different image as
the background for that title section
and let me let me show you what that
looks like in case you you're watching
for the first time or you didn't see it
here's kind of an example of the title
section okay so this is the actual
section that's being rendered it has a
background image and then it has the
title about okay so the two thing the
only two things that will probably
change the background image and about
we're going to change a third thing so
I'll actually code in another prop live
so you can see how it's done okay the
other thing we're putting in is the
image path and that goes in
actually this does go in the background
image so this is a little tricky let me
show you how this how we did this so
we've added this is just a normal style
tag like we put if we wanted to do an
inline style
I just glanced the livestream again
sorry I know I said I was going to do
that but somebody said they're from
Narnia again and I just I think that's
that's awesome if you're not familiar
there's a series of books that take
place in this imaginary world card
called Narnia and they're good books
actually I read the whole series to my
kids about a year or two ago it was it
was fun so let me scroll over so all
that's going on here is this is a
background image property inside this
style tag so we've dropped into
JavaScript right and then we're making
an object with that's what these second
brackets are so we can see this is just
you know normal a normal JavaScript
object okay we normally you wouldn't
write it all in line like this but it's
a basic JavaScript object let me see if
I can let me put it in a way that maybe
will look a little bit more familiar to
you so I would normally make a component
like this but just for the sake of the
demonstration so it's easier for
everybody to see
I'm going to break this down
okay
I don't even know if this would actually
work with all the spaces and stuff in it
but but it's easier to see so this looks
let's break this down okay so this
probably makes it look a little bit
better why you style an HTML put
everything in the stylesheet well one
reason to put it in the HTML we'll see
in a second you can do either way if you
want your components on my feeling is if
I want my components to be really
modular so that I can use them not just
on different pages in the same site but
on totally different sites then it's
probably a good idea to put all the
Styles you would want for that component
within the component so I don't always
do that I probably won't do it for all
the components for this site just
because of the compressed timeline and
that the launch date that's coming up
soon but I think it's a cool concept to
make your components completely
self-contained and able to be reused the
the goal my goal for for the university
that I work for is to have a set of
react components that are completely
self-contained that have the the styles
that we like to use for our sites and
that other people could use so somebody
another department maybe a you know
maybe the IT department has a developer
that can just take those styles and use
it and they don't have to know anything
about the design or anything about how
we make components but they can just use
that component so I get to sum up you
can do it really either way and you
don't have to put it in line I'll show
you probably not in this video but
another video you know you can put your
Styles in a variable and then it will
look more like a normal style sheet but
in this case we have the style
background image it's a little bit
different normally you'd say background
- image but this is JavaScript so we're
going to camelcase this and say
background image and pretty much I
haven't come across anything that
doesn't have a camel
equivalent there might be some sort of
CSS property that is different if you
have one that's different usually I
think this this works if you did
something like this like let's say you
didn't camel case and you made it the
normal way with the - you could put it
in quotes and that should work I haven't
tried in a while though but I think on a
previous project it works is this a
background image we're just adding this
this gradient this might look weird to
you if you're not familiar with es6 or I
think it's officially called es2015 it's
some new JavaScript syntax this is the
template literal syntax the set little
backtick that's right underneath the
Escape key on the keyboard and I'll show
you what's awesome about this in a
second when we scroll over so what we're
doing here is we just have a linear
gradient as our first background we've
added a comma in and now we're adding
our second background which is the image
this is kind of a nice way to add an
overlay of your image without having to
make an extra div and trying to position
it you just make the gradient the same
so this is these are exactly the same
values and then it looks like a solid
overlay instead of your normal gradient
that fades in to a different color so
we've got a URL part now normally we
would just type in a URL here but we
want to be able to change that so in
this case we put this Propps image path
but we had to do it differently
so here's here's what we've dropped in
at this point after the style tag see
this part is still like HTML stuff as
soon as we put that bracket we've gone
into JavaScript mode so this between
these two brackets this is all
JavaScript so this part is basically a
string this whole part is just a string
well normally if you had a sure
and you wanted to put JavaScript in
there you would end your string you
would put a plus sign and then you would
put your JavaScript and then you put
another plus sign and you would start a
new string right let me know if you're
not if this is not making sense if this
is totally new to you maybe we might
need to watch it again if I'm going too
fast or ask me some questions put in the
comments I'll be happy to go over it
again but with instead of doing all
those plus signs we use this template
literal syntax which is a tick here this
back tick here and a back tick on the
end inside that so it's just a string
inside it so you can use that and it's
exactly the same as using a single quote
or a double quote but the cool thing you
can do is if you put dollar sign curly
bracket now you can write javascript in
there you end the JavaScript with just
one more curly bracket and now you're
right back into a string I can also use
both single quotes and double quotes
inside this template literal syntax ease
back text without breaking the string so
normally if you had a double quoted
string and you try to put more double
quotes inside you're going to break up
the string so this is really cool I am
I'm kind of considering just making
these my default go-to for four strings
the only reason I haven't is I'm just so
used to using usually single quotes in
my JavaScript that by habit I put it in
here so you see I've done it here but
really these are so much more useful not
every browser supports this so you will
need to transpile that and I'll probably
do a video on transpiling basically if
you're not familiar transpiling it would
just transform this into older style
JavaScript that more browsers can use so
it would take these out put in regular
quotes put in some plus signs and do all
this but
next which is what we use to build this
app a few days ago or to build this
react site a few days ago comes built in
with es6 support so we don't have to
worry about it this is going to get
transpiled if we put this inside of our
components does that make sense I have
the last unit in pretty dead this whole
time so either it makes sense or I've
just lost everybody but let me know so
that was a lot so let's do one let's
let's code one right now and kind of
take you through the steps sometimes it
could be hard to read it when it's
already done so we'll go through the
steps I'm just going to go back on all
this so it's back to where I had it
before whoops
area almost back all right I think
that's back to where it was great so
what I want to do what I'd like to do
let me bring this in for you to see I'm
gonna bring this site again and show you
the problem that we have the problem is
each image that we're going to use in
the background it they don't always work
in terms of the part of the image that
shows up here so sometimes you would
just see like the sky and you wouldn't
see the buildings you wouldn't see all
this landscaping or you just see the
very bottom part so we want to make some
way to easily change the positioning so
kind of show you let me show you right
now the original positioning was about
like this that's that's not really what
we want so
all I'm doing now I have dev tools open
in my other window I'm just changing the
CSS attribute called background position
Y so I'm changing it up that I'm using
right now this is actually set at
negative 46 VH and that gives us you
know pretty nice section you can see as
we move the screen it pretty much stays
in that spot it does it's not the
greatest-looking thing on a small screen
but it's not terrible maybe we might put
in some alternate images or small
screens at some point also for some
reason this I might need a better
quality image I just pulled these from
the old site and I don't know that
doesn't look great to me so the image
itself might need some work but the
basic principle is the same so what we
need to do then is we need to go to that
background position Y so the background
image is on this section let me scroll
over here this is all just within that
style attributes though these are inline
Styles which as someone mentioned in a
live stream in the react way it's it's
not looked down upon to mix CSS with
your HTML inline it's a really weird way
to look at it there's actually a video
where they explain why they did it like
that the people who made react if I can
maybe I'll try to remember to find the
link to that and put it in the
description just to give you an idea of
it definitely is strange if you're not
used to seeing it okay so let's see the
background position Y this is where I'm
at right now so you see I actually have
it right now it's set to 100% and dev
tools I had a change but what we
actually want to do is we want to make
this
I'll be able to be a prop that's passed
in so right now remember we're inside
this draw the script portion and we're
also inside a string so what I want to
do is change this to use that backtick
between you take advantage of that
template literal syntax okay so now this
is still a string but we have the
ability now to do this which brings us
back into JavaScript so we can do this
props and let's see what we want to name
this let's just say say shorthand
counter for position y you can name your
your properties anything you want it
doesn't really matter okay so we have
this in here now let's go back to about
and we're just going to add in here
where we have our our title our title
component being pulled in we're going to
add in another property another
attribute called position Y and we're
going to set that equal to what do we
say this negative 44 VH I'm going to
save that let's go back and check it out
and see if it works all right it looks
good I'm going to check it out really
quick in dev tools on my other screen to
make sure that it in fact did pull over
okay we have negative 44 V H I'm going
to refresh it just to triple check and
make sure that this still works and it's
looking good on dev tools it's looking
good over here okay so it works so what
we've done here is now we've we've given
anyone editing this the ability to
change
the wide position of that background
image - whatever they want without
having to actually edit this title
component they never have to go in here
never have to change any of this and now
we can change three things about this
title component string from the page
where we're importing it we can change
the title we can change the the image
and Spain use and the vertical the Y
position of that image and we can reuse
this on every single page so what I'm
probably going to do as soon as I'm done
this livestream is I'm going to copy and
paste this on all the other pages unless
I can figure out some way to save myself
from copy and pasting this which there
there may be some way to do some sort of
overall layout component and next maybe
I'll read the documentation since we
don't have a lot of pages is probably
going to be faster for me to just copy
and paste but on a larger site we may
want to think of some other way to do
that so all right it's 2:30
exactly I said I'd go back to the live
stream so the tutorial parts pretty much
done if you don't want to stick around
I'm going to go to the live chat now
check out if there's any questions and
try to answer some questions before we
before we end so let me scroll up all
right so we have people shouting out
where they're from Germany South Africa
Netherlands Nairobi Ghana Alabama
Guatemala Philippines San Francisco
India Ukraine Syria North Pole Alaska
farthest Wow somebody they said they
might be the farthest north I think
you're definitely the person that's the
farthest north that I can remember it's
Paul said that Montreal Portugal wit
Narnia uh let's see
okay
Samuel Kaiser which I'm sorry if I
mispronounced anybody's names I'll try
the best I can
asks what's the head component he's
using so I don't think I explained this
I apologize this is something that next
j/s has built-in we can import head from
next head so anything time we're
importing something from next this
directory it's something built in from
next and basically what this does is it
lets me put a custom head tag in any of
my pages so I can change the stuff in
here and that will go into the head of
that that page when it gets rendered so
that's nice for well like we have
different titles for the pages we may
not need to load everything if we're not
using you know the same fonts or styles
so that's where that comes from that's
this a built in thing you can read more
about it within the documentation for
next Jas which I think I have linked
already in the description and now I
just scrolled down and saw that Samuel
Keizer just did exactly that he checked
the description and checked out next J s
and found the answer to it so maybe I
should have scroll down a little bit
more to see but yes that would be good
for anybody's watching this later on and
has a similar question people are asking
about the code editor I'm using it is
Adam I have a link to that in the
description if you want to check out
Adam I'm using the SETI theme SETI some
from Australia from UK Sweden India
Somalia Scotland Italy Ukraine Pakistan
England Thailand Poland hey Poland I
have relatives that came from from
Poland on my mom's side my mom's parents
were on one side Polish and on the other
side Italian so I had a lot of love for
Poland and all right so that's it for
the live stream if you're still sticking
around after all that I know I went a
few minutes over I want to make sure I
got your questions if you have any other
questions let me know in the comments if
you don't want everybody to see your
question direct message me on Twitter I
will be back tomorrow at 2 p.m. next
week's going to be a weird schedule if
you missed the beginning of the video go
back and re-watch it I have explained
what the schedule is going to be like
next next week and why thanks again for
watching and I'll see you tomorrow